when people mention a film version of
babes in toyland usually the Disney ones
the first one that comes to mind and
that either means that's really good or
all the other film versions range from
bad to really bad and yeah that's kind
of my outlook on it I love this film
growing up but watching it again it
doesn't hold up that great it's got a
lot of good people and the money in the
production definitely shows but in terms
of the story and the main character it's
kind of all over the place and pretty
bland surprising for a film that looks
like this okay well what's the story
Mary and Tom are just two of the most
adorable lovebirds and they're gonna get
married but Barnaby the evil villain of
the town decides that he wants to marry
Mary how do I know this because he
literally tells the audience I'm to get
my hands on Mary's money the person Mary
married must be me not Tom me so he
sends his two henchmen to have Tom
killed but the henchmen decide they can
make a little money on the side to
something decide to sell them to a bunch
of gypsies now that Tom is gone Mary
sees that her only choice is to marry
Barnaby why get this she can't do the
math on her finances no I'm not even
kidding there's a whole trippy ass song
dedicated to it this is much too hard
for us we can't do the some Barnaby of
course accepts the offer to marry her
and calls it a bunch of gypsies for
entertainment and when Genoa Tom's in
the Gypsy band and of course they get
back together but then we shift to kind
of another story as a bunch of the kids
wander into the forest of no return and
Tom and Mary go to try and save them
only to run to a toymaker who makes a
device that can shrink things down but
then Barnaby seems to follow him and he
shrinks everybody down and uses that as
leverage to still marry Mary but then
Tom breaks open a bunch of the toys and
they had this big epic battle and this
is weird so yeah as you can tell from
the story it's kind of all over the
place and like I said weird I'm usually
fine with weird but this movie clearly
doesn't have much of a focus and
kind of obvious because there's nothing
really that much interesting to focus on
at least in terms of the main characters
that's a net full of cello as Mary and
she's usually very charming but she just
has nothing to work with here oh she
does his cry and look confused the guy
who plays Tom has a funny scene as a
gypsy fortune-teller but aside from that
he has nothing really that interesting
the kids are all boring some of the side
characters are kind of neat but they're
not in it for very long a lot of songs
are pretty pointless though some of them
are kind of fun the only thing that's
genuinely enjoyable about it is the
villain recognize him yeah that's the
Scarecrow from Wizard of Oz and he just
has a great time being the most
stereotypical villain but really playing
it up and having fun this is the guy
with the top hat twiddles his mustache
tied the woman to the railroad tracks
the whole schpeel and his two bumbling
sidekicks actually get a few laughs - I
also like Edie win as the toymaker
because well he said win anything he's
in it's just gonna be a ton of fun even
if it sucks aside from that like I said
the look of the production is really
impressive I mean yeah it's obviously a
set but it's such a big set and it's so
creative with all the colors and the
costumes and the puppets and it looks
really imagine to do even it is sort of
dressed in that 60's and 70's style that
dates it a bit but not too bad the music
and songs as well though not always
necessary are it's still nice to listen
to I could listen to that march of the
toy soldiers forever and yeah we've
heard it in a bunch of our different
versions but man does it sound good here
enter the hole climax is a lot of fun
you spend this good long while building
up this toy army with that incredible
music and this wonderful stop-motion
these great effects and what does
Barnaby do when they finally come in he
just laughs at them it's sort of like
yeah they're just toys why am i afraid
of you
but as they keep fighting on and on and
on they tend to get more and more
threatening until Mary throws that
potion at him that shrinks him down and
it's an enjoyable one-on-one battle
between our hero and villain
even though Mary clearly could just go
and step on him but yeah it's more
traumatic this way so again like almost
any Disney production even if it's bad
there's some really cool stuff in it I
do like the scope and size of the
production I do like the villains and I
like a lot of music but outside of that
the story and main characters are just
so hopelessly dull but again as a kid I
did watch it a lot but yeah maybe it was
for those three elements I listed
earlier I did tend to fast-forward it
whenever Tom or Mary were on-screen I
don't know if you're looking for an
impressive-looking kids film without
much substance to it you'll get your
fill but you're looking for a timeless
classic based on a timeless classic
babes in toyland this is probably not
the best interpretation or maybe it is
in film form but come on there's got to
be better looks great sounds great but
not too much else to it
you